The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah.
But he's sending a mountain lion.
Well you know,
one just died,
a famous one just died where I got a text from Manila out here.
Um,
he,
uh,
eight some rat poison.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
That's a real problem with rat poison man.
Rat poison doesn't just affect rats.
You know,
there's like there's secondary and my dog this tied that way.
Yeah.
And what it does is the rat poison I think stops you from producing vitamin K in
your body,
which is like,
which is how you clot blood.
Oh.
So they just bleed internally.
So my dog yet load of it and they pumped his stomach,
gave him charcoal and then he had to take vitaminK supplements for a long time.
Wow.
Yeah.
The people,
they poison the rats than things eat the rats,
you know?
Yeah.
This a mountain lion is a famous mountain lion collared one.
The tracking.
Yeah.
Out here.
A number ever Rinella texted me about it and then I looked into it.
Oh,
you got it there.
What does,
which number does it say here?
47 [inaudible] 47 is not the one that they spotted at the not,
no.
This one's only three.
We were going to get a photo of that,
right?
Yeah,
let's do that.
Oh yeah.
We tracked it down.
Yeah.
What happened is expensive.
Yeah,
let's,
let's do that though.
Let me know after the show.
Which one you wanted.
The artist's proof,
whatever we got that detail of it or whatever.
Yeah,
because that one photo that they caught of it.
Have you seen that photo of the lion with the Hollywood sign behind it?
No.
It's amazing.
It's one of the best.
It's an,
again,
it's so fucking human cause this line has a collar on it like it's got bling on
stand in front of the Hollywood sign and it's as big as fuck.
It's all that.
It's like 150 a mile a minute.
Oh,
that's amazing.
Look at that photo.
That looks stage looked staged.
By the way.
Look at the look at the muscles plead it's forearms.
Yeah.
That's a ridiculous animal.
That's one thing that people don't,
I don't think you've realized like that's not a [inaudible] thing.
Like a house.
That's a lion,
sir.
They have enormous forearms.
Yeah.
It's a lion that ways putting down an elk.
I bet that's 130 pounds.
Yeah.
Maybe 150 think about how big that is.
That doesn't seem big,
but you see a rottweiler,
a police dog like that or shepherd 90 pounds.
Yeah.
Good luck.
Yeah,
good luck.
That's an add.
Add another 60 pounds.
40 pounds of,
that's a big animal,
man.
Yeah.
Such a big animal and they're just wandering around our neighborhoods.
Factive killers.
If I'm having a guy come on who is a mountain lion biologist at Topanga Canyon.
Oh really?
Yeah,
and I might actually go and trap one with him.
How many them?
How many do they think there are others?
There's quite a few.
This one at one 50 wow.
Dale,
the one that died.
Wow.
150 that was a big cat.
Jesus.
Crazy.
Three years old.
Jesus Christ.
He was 150 pounds.
Just living on deer.
Yeah.
Go look around for deer in California.
Good luck.
Yeah,
they know deer out here.
There's so few deer have,
you're a deer hunter in California.
Your sad face.
Oh,
you around.
You're not looking forward to it.
And yet I see a lot of deer in Topanga.
Yeah.
You See al few,
they're drawn to me.
Oh,
I feed them.
Are you,
um,
it's my alpha energy.
They feel safe with me,
but is do you have a connection with them,
do you think?
To be honest with you,
I run with them.
Have you always been like this?
They flanked me.
They would never go past me.
They flank pain.
When I do my Kung folded open field,
they surround me and they bow and until I released them and I go,
Huh,
okay.